edificios destruidos calcinados
aquí en boro dianca a una hora de kiev
más de 700 apartamentos fueron
destruidos
lo que queda de las edificaciones ha
sido asegurado expertos fueron a evaluar
los daños pero cuánto tiempo se
mantendrán de pie estos edificios la
reconstrucción es ahora la prioridad
en dos o tres semanas destruyeron no
sólo los edificios sino también la vida
hoy por día está lista para comenzar el
proceso de renovación pero necesitamos
materiales de reconstrucción y mano de
obra queremos que la gente que huyó
pueda regresar pero desgraciadamente no
tienen un lugar donde vivir
el 90% de la población huyó de la ciudad
durante la ocupación rusa solo la mitad
de ellos han decidido volver desde
principios de junio algunos habitantes
viven aquí en estas viviendas
prefabricadas financiadas por polonia
una ayuda muy valiosa para anahí
submarinas
y estamos muy agradecidos por esto
gracias al gobierno polaco y a todas las
personas que nos cuidan especialmente a
todos los voluntarios
el centro de albergue tiene capacidad
para 350 personas muchas como anna
tendrán que permanecer allí durante
meses quizás incluso años
entren por favor
no queda nada de su casa pero ana sigue
sonriendo está bien
miren
vivíamos allá en el cuarto piso
ese era nuestro balcón se puede ver que
había una escalera miren la siguiente
foto se cayó
desde nuestra habitación uno cae al
vacío
bombardeos aéreos bombardeos desde la
calle el centro de la ciudad devoró
dianca no se libró de los rusos cuando
uno llega aquí se da cuenta de la
magnitud de los daños la reconstrucción
llevará años
la destrucción es colosal en todo el
país en milán a unos 30 kilómetros de
kiev los voluntarios trabajan para
despejar el último piso de este edificio
quedó completamente destruido en un
bombardeo
ya lo sé
soy de gerson pasé 50 días bajo la
ocupación rusa conseguido huir hace un
mes y medio parte de mi familia sigue
allá y hacia acá no tengo dinero ni
trabajo pero quiero ayudar a mi país
cómo puedo hacerlo enviando estos
escombros en lugares como este
volé aquí en compañía de su vecina huyó
del barrio con su mujer y su hija el día
del bombardeo
vivían en el quinto piso
dos disparos de tanques impactaron esta
habitación
el fuego lo destruyó todo aquí es donde
dormía nuestra pequeña fuimos blanco
también
digamos que nos piden unos años parte
del techo derrumbado ha sido reparado
pero el apartamento sigue siendo
inhabitable en su estado actual los
habitantes del edificio han contribuido
a financiar las obras
es para que el edificio no se inunde por
la lluvia y la nieve
la ayuda estatal será entregada hasta
entre un año si es que hay porque la
guerra sigue
a pocos kilómetros de milán dmitri para
las autoridades de la región de kiev
coordinan los trabajos de reconstrucción
las donaciones proceden principalmente
de empresas de construcción ya se han
construido cinco casas
se espera que se reconstruyan otras 15
más
[Música]
para reconstruir todos los edificios
necesitamos más de 30 millones de
dólares
reparaciones de esta magnitud son
imposibles solo con voluntarios
pero nos vemos limitados por la cuestión
de dónde y cómo conseguirlo
más de 24.000 kilómetros de carreteras
han sufrido daños desde el inicio de la
guerra 300 puentes han sido destruidos
ucrania ya ha reparado lo que ha podido
pero el trabajo sigue siendo enorme y se
necesita dinero el país espera poder
contar con la ayuda de europa la factura
es colosal
según nuestros cálculos esta estimación
aumenta cada día una cifra asciende a
más de 100 mil millones de dólares
es imposible imaginar la reconstrucción
de ucrania sin ayuda exterior y por
supuesto nos gustaría que rusia pagará
por esto porque vinieron a nuestro país
dañaron nuestra infraestructura
destruyeron nuestras ciudades deben
pagar
pero confiscar los activos rusos será
legalmente complicado y no será
suficiente para reconstruir el país
mientras la guerra no termine la factura
seguirá creciendo